hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
so I posted a picture on on patreon
showing that I was attending Justice
League IMAX I got a lot more from it the
second time I watched it I said like do
you guys want to hear my second thoughts
I think one person said yes and I took
that as everyone wants to hear my second
thoughts Oh real quick I want to give a
shout out to a guy named Brandon I
didn't catch his last name when I was
walking out of the theater Brandon this
tall black guy with his equally tall
beautiful black girlfriend they're black
I don't know why I'm specifying that so
much it's just my thing I guess he
seemed like kind of nervous to talk to
me his girlfriend had to tell me his
name and I thought it was really
adorable yeah he said he's like a big
fan of the channel and I'm like ah dude
you're so sweet we hugged he's a really
great guy you hear that John the rejects
are in with the black community I'm not
saying we have we have black friends
that's when you call your subscribers
friends doesn't it work I'm mocking
YouTube so John was not with me do you
know what I had so you did not have
second viewing experience that's why
he's on this video so I saw this film on
IMAX this time a real IMAX screen at
Universal CityWalk about halfway through
it start dawning on me why I started
feeling even better about this is if you
watch my first review that I did with
John I admit that the film's pretty
cheesy it's corny and it definitely has
its flaws I was still really entertained
so this is a no way me going I hated it
the first time but I loved it the second
time I really liked it the first time I
thought it was very entertaining film
the second time I walked out saying I
love this movie there's a few
contributions as to why first reason is
watching an IMAX made a big difference
not because it's just IMAX and by Max is
chlorophyll it's because they
specifically shop is with certain IMAX
cameras a lot of the time when I was
watching on the first time which is just
a regular 2d screen I kept feeling like
the visual effects were really off
beyond Steppenwolf it felt like a lot of
it was off and I felt like a lot of that
had to do with the lighting and I think
I even made commentary about that
specifically in regards
Steppenwolf here's what I'll say
Steppenwolf still doesn't look great no
matter what I mix crude you put a lot he
still looks like a ps3 video again every
other aspect to it I mean there are
certain times where you know when
Superman's flying Steppenwolf where he
looks like Agent Smith out of the Matrix
Reloaded or when the ship takes off and
alfred is standing at the water and he
still looks like a videogame but a lot
of the other visuals that I thought were
like a little bit distracting just look
significantly better on IMAX especially
the scene in that mascara that whole
sequence looked amazing first time I
watched it I was kind of distracted this
time around even the Steppenwolf's parts
I noticed whoa he's actually kind of
scary here this time around and the
sound design mixes way better so I feel
like the experience for this film is a
little more accustomed foreign IMAX so
beyond that that's just the technical
standpoint that I'm talking about as far
as just a movie going experience overall
I think a lot of this would play better
on a second viewing and I bumped into a
few people Brendan the guy I met this
was his fourth time watching and he says
he gets better
every time he watches it and I could see
this being that kind of film this is a
night that I won you know it's opening
night there's been a lot of talk about
delays and the production problems
behind the scenes and it's coming off of
BBS and Suicide Squad you know I don't
wonder woman's in between all that but a
lot of people are really going back to
those because Batman's leading this and
Superman is back in his so there's all
this these thoughts just going through
your head sometimes it makes it a little
challenging just to sit back relax and
enjoy the movie instead of having you're
observant ion and when you have that
observant eye on or sometimes a critical
eye you could walk away thinking a
little bit more about the things you had
issues with as opposed to the things you
have problems with and that's probably
the main difference that I had with a
second viewing I didn't really care or
think about the problems like there's
still some of them are still there
evidently just overall I really walked
away thinking about what I loved about
this film I didn't really notice it the
first time the opening of this movie
it's during that
Spider Man homecoming think sounds like
recording Superman and he asks him what
do you love most about Earth
he looks off to the side and he gives
this smile and then the movie pretty
much
starts goes into its prologue with
Batman hunting down a para demon when
Superman doesn't answer it I remembered
being in the theatre the first time with
observational highs on being like oh my
god Superman still can't ask her why he
loves her he doesn't love her seems like
it man is stealing BBS he hates being
Superman even my my girlfriend who I was
taking her for the first time to watch
this movie she even made that comment
out loud I realized the second viewing
oh he's talking about Lois Lane at the
beginning of the movie when he smiles he
wants to say Lois what I really
appreciated about this film on a second
viewing was I saw a lot more of what
they're going for and I think with
having already being introduced to these
characters like cyborg and flash and
Aquaman already on a first viewing I
don't have my observant eye on thinking
about the information I got to gather
the points I got to take about who these
guys are on a second viewing it actually
felt like yeah that was plenty enough
for flash I thought that was plenty and
cyborg I thought was one of the
strongest characters after first viewing
and I feel like he is still one of the
strongest characters out of the Justice
League movie because his first scene is
just so powerful when he's walking
around he's telling his dad about it he
gets these upgrades alien upgrades and
he has this line ever since Superman
came to this planet people have been
worrying about the next alien invasion
he wonders if he's it and that really
hit home for me the first time and I
kind of forgot about that because it's
so early in the movie but the second
time I'm watching it I'm realizing how
effective that one line of dialogue
really is for cyborgs character and the
other thing too is because observant I
was on so much in the first viewing I
felt like and I feel like a lot of
people were saying this that the film
feels kind of rushed the second time
around I didn't feel like it was a
rushed movie going experience I actually
thought it had a really good pacing and
it took its time pretty well pretty much
each and every scene I wasn't ever
sitting there being like this is moving
way too fast whereas opposed the first
time I felt like it was moving really
fast even action sequences where I had a
harder time picking up what was really
going on I was able to really see what
was really going on and it just made me
appreciate the whole viewing experience
a whole lot more and the other note I
took from it was how the film kind of
starts off at a darker a little
melancholy spot and the film
progressively gets lighter as it keeps
going which I thought was a unique touch
I think that when you go into Justice
League and you think of end of the world
scenario you're expecting a film I kind
of might get progressively darker as it
keeps going so that way you really feel
the impact of end of the world being at
stake and all that to be truthfully
honest with you I feel like with the
amount of films we get about end of the
world happening that no matter how hard
justice lee tried even if they tried
harder and had you know another half
hour to this movie I don't think I would
have bought those steaks either way
because I'm so sick of that scenario
with that I didn't really care about it
anymore I found myself walking away a
second time going I just really love
this team I really love these actors I
love their chemistry and I do feel that
the film has a lot more character and
humanity that you can gather from it the
second viewing experience and I
appreciate how this film does start off
on a darker side you know it's like
Superman you don't feel like Superman's
been reinvented from the very first
scene when you cut to Batman he's in
Gotham City and that was another note I
took I feel like when you walk away from
this movie of first time there are some
moments and scenes and especially
Steppenwolf where the aura just looks
awful in terms of visual effects it just
looks awful so you walk away being like
the visual effects are pretty bad in
this movie the second time I'm watching
it I'm like how come no one ever talks
about good CGI anymore this film when
they're in Gotham I'm like this is
beautiful especially on IMAX and the
first time I watched it I thought it -
this looks so amazing the the the Gotham
visuals are a delight and this is one
thing you got to give this movie over
most Marvel films there's a unique
cinematography to this movie and there's
such distinct visuals and framing you
just don't get that kind of style with a
lot of other comic-book movies and I
really feel like the Justice League
movie has so many shots in it where
you're like this looks straight out of a
comic book and I love it it does tend a
lot to that inner child within who loves
the comics or who just loved like the
Saturday morning cartoons or like
watching these characters crossover and
shows and when the film starts off
darker you know with Batman and even
Wonder Woman it's like even that's a
lighter tone
with her cuz it's Wonder Woman she's
still dealing with a pretty dark
scenario they walk into a bank they're
gunning down human beings in a building
this guy wants to blow up a part of the
city because you know darkness a Dark
Ages are coming and flash going to see
his dad and cyborgs where he's at I
really appreciated how this film the
second time I got it I got more of what
they were intending which was that
feeling of heroism I walked away feeling
the unit it sounds cheesy [ __ ] it's so
it's true even they say unites the
league that's what I felt was a sense of
unity from the team I walked away way
less thinking about the issues I had
with it because at the end of day I did
show up to show just to see the Justice
League United yes what I have like
Steppenwolf to have been a better
villain of course I would have because
that would have made the Team Dynamics
feel even stronger that would have made
the mission in itself feel even stronger
but these characters own personal
journeys I found engaging enough by the
end of the movies I really felt that
when Superman says I like living or I
like being alive one of those lines I
really walked away from that moment
being like this is why Superman is able
to be reinvented cuz he died and now
he's back so he's been reinvented he
likes living so it makes sense why he's
all smiles and stuff for some reason I
didn't really notice it the first time I
watched it because I was so taken back
by that one line by Superman but cyborg
says the same line too right with
Superman and I said audibly the second
time watching this I went oh good side
where he likes to live now you have
cyborgs journey coming to terms with he
wants to live and he can see himself
being a hero and this is a gift that he
has and flash with getting a job making
his dad happy and making some friends
he's grown Batman successfully doing his
job as a leader I found effective and
Wonder Woman deciding to be a beacon of
hope again designed to be a light
instead of hiding I am a little
questionable still what she like has
those bad guys at the end tied up and
she just has her face showing because
I'm thinking anyone she's done work with
it will now know that she's Wonder Woman
I don't know if she's aiming or keeping
it a secret identity or not but the fact
that she's out in the light so that's
why when it gets all heroic cheesy in
the finale I didn't mind it I really
don't mind it when Alfred's like it's
not the plan it's the team and he has
the secure piece smile on his face then
they all defeat the date if he
Steppenwolf and they're all doing their
heroic poses side-by-side with each
other it's cheesy but rewarding at the
same time I felt that hope I felt that
light as opposed to its observational
the first time I'm watching it and I
have to really soak all this information
and for me it's easier to sit back and
relax and enjoy it on a second viewing
experience and I walked away being like
you know what I love this film it's
really entertaining yes then defeating
Steppenwolf is a part of the plot an
important part I walked away enough with
these characters own personal journey
and that's what matter to me most was
watching these guys grow and that's why
I think a lot of us are still very
excited to see their own solo adventures
and as far as visual effects being
better even when they go to Atlantis I
thought that looked absolutely horrible
the first time I watched it watching an
IMAX it looks so much better not because
it's bigger but they obviously adjust
their visual style for the IMAX cameras
you have to always adjust for whatever
camera you're shooting on so when you're
seeing on the format it's meant to be
seen on it just looks better last thing
Superman's moustache printing I don't
even notice it I I don't you know like I
I think I said in the review that one
time I noticed it and then the second
time watching and I'm like hey I really
I really can't notice it's not a big
deal Superman's the best part of this
baby so I gotta say you know I don't
think this film deserves a thirty eight
percent or 40 percent whatever it's at
on Rotten Tomatoes the user score is
really high most people are bumping into
her saying they really enjoyed the film
and if you like listened to a lot of the
reviews on YouTube most people seem to
be saying they overall they have really
enjoyed the film for this Ron tomato
score to be so low is this [ __ ] to
begin with and Rotten Tomatoes isn't
everything I know that I just think it
might be playing a factor into the box
office experience when I think this is a
wonderful movie going experience I think
it's a fantastic experience to go to the
theaters and check it out I encourage
more people to go watch this movie and
if anything I encourage you guys to go
watch it again if you've only seen it
one time cuz you might be like me and
realize this film is even better than
you thought I already liked it the first
time now I love it and I know one person
who didn't really like it and they said
the second time I saw it they actually
ended up liking it the best comparison I
could give it is honesty Dark Knight
Rises first time I saw the Dark Knight
Rises I didn't really like it I walked
away thinking about all the problems
with the
film second time I watched it which was
on IMAX the visual aesthetic works
better because it's shot with IMAX
cameras and secondly I walk away
thinking a lot more about what I like
about the film than the things I had
issues with go watch Justice League
again if you've learned only seen him
one time I highly encourage you so if
you guys have seen it twice 1ch leave a
comment down below and give me your
thoughts on what you thought about it
second time watching it was it better
the second time was it worse the second
time for me personally I thought it was
even better than the first time and I
yeah I I feel like they really
accomplished this film you guys can
subscribe but the real rejects click
that notification bell follow us on
social media right now the reject
community is a big part of the Stardust
app or really making sure to include
that with us you do 30 second reactions
for any film TV show or trailer and if
you'd like to see more exclusive daily
posts from the real reject which are
usually a video or two go check out our
patreon become a patron eject today what
helps support the channel and in return
we try to give you guys a lot of stuff
worthwhile as well so thank you